[Music]
so the games been out for over a month
now and many players and fans of the
theories have completed most if not all
the story and shrines in the game with
that being said I feel that it's now an
okay time to have an honest review of
the game breath of the wild in a
nutshell while the early game is strong
with brethren wild later game players
will experience more of a repetitious
mode of play now what do I mean well as
well okay what I mean by this the
survival aspect but you really feel at
first it's fantastic that first time you
exit that cave and you're really wowed
by the huge map in front of you and you
fight your first book oblems with a
stick and you find your first shield and
you scrap together enough mushrooms and
apples and maybe a fish if you're a real
pro and cook your first meal is just
amazing there's no other Zelda
experience quite like this truthfully
now in contrast to the end game playing
environment there are a few things that
begin to happen firstly the variety of
enemies is limited greatly in that not
including mini bosses of which there are
four types throughout Hyrule there are
the cobble ins rare Yuga light and heavy
assassins Marlins Guardians lizalfos Wiz
Rose Lionel's and the little guys like
you choose Keys ox ox and petted now
these enemies do have their subspecies
and so forth like the Selma plants that
appear at night or the bliz Rose or the
savage Lionel but they're all defeated
the same way as the every other kind of
that enemy a player like myself who
split more than a hundred hours into the
game will have memorized by this time
every move set and every tendency of the
enemies that you face regardless of
their color I mean I mean difficulty
level the only actually unique enemy to
fight is the line and even they get old
after a little while just being honest
the many bosses that pop up or appear
randomly throughout Hyrule are so
incredibly easy that I almost consider
the only formidable mini-bosses to be
the Lionel's I would have liked to see
the return of some classic enemies like
boku plants or pose or dark nuts or
skull Chile's or wolf pose or three
heads or I don't know any kind of water
enemy besides in ofter
or heck even new enemies to the Zelda
universe but that's just me asking too
much
too much mass Nintendo bandits aren't
you happy with all this world yes yes I
am I really am all in all the enemies
were not lacking at all in number
however the basic movesets and weaponry
that has shared among them all makes for
a rather bland experience then not as
heated of a desire to search each and
every enemy camp you come across and
game like you would have done when you
first started playing and everything was
new and fresh secondly the story was
good just good not like blow me out of
the water fantastic but it was good I
would put it at the level of the
original Legend of Zelda which was its
goal just plus cinematics and voice
acting in the future I'd like to see a
return to the whole actually playing
through the story thing that's been
characteristic of Zelda games since a
Link to the Past but the rest of the
world it did work the whole
post-apocalyptic doomsday style approach
did indeed work for this game and like I
said it was good now I would like to
have some characters that I dealt with
for more than I don't know 15 minutes
total of dialogue or just characters
that showed more emotion period like
okay remember the Goron descendant of
the route that you just kind of save and
then use for that one mission going up
to the divine beast Varro Dania yeah I
loved that guy I thought his personality
was hilarious I loved his little mohawk
laughed out loud whenever he was panning
really hard when I'd run too far in
front of him or he gets so scared when
an enemy was nearby when I shot him like
a cannonball at heart Tanya oh those
were good times I enjoyed that
I thought he was going to be around for
a longer after that segment their game
nope you just do that and then he's an
NPC who repeats two lines of dialogue
for the rest of the game the point is
but what's better a bunch of characters
with little development for a few
characters with a lot of development I
suppose that's left a personal
preference thirdly the gameplay of
course is phenomenal everything I
expected to be so much more I mean I'm
still discovering recipes I just
discovered that you can make different
varieties of curry rice this morning
like what I love chicken link hey hey
but that's probably bad for you like you
need to stop and cook that first dude do
aren't you afraid of Salmonella link
Salmonella we're gonna die and the
weaponry you find is super awesome I
mean there's only three kinds of melee
weapons but their variety and pretty
looks are pretty sweet plus they keep
dropping a greater and greater power
levels for me and I haven't really
figured out what determines that just
yet but anyway they do need more bows
however also more arrow drops like I
went through the entire game with only
30 or fewer arrows at any one given time
and only just now have more than 300
because I went and bought every single
arrow I could find from every vendor I
came across I can honestly say that
after completing every shrine nearly
every side quest and discovering the
entire map the only real thing that
still gives me actual enjoyment is just
exploring just walking in one direction
killing enemies and taking up core of
fear that in hunting down materials
needed for all my armor upgrades the
star Dragon's be damned
this is what breath of the wild was
meant to be after all just exploration
all wonder oh yeah and rain lots and
lots of unnecessary emotionally and just
plain rude rain yes oh very close it is
I'm not really going to touch on the
dungeons and or shrines in the game too
much because well I ripped into them
pretty bad my other video breath the
wild versus Ocarina of Time which by the
way you should check out at the end
basically though I enjoyed all of it I
really wish the divine beast dungeons
were longer and that there are even more
varied shrines and strong quests but a
120 shrine plus 4 dungeons is more than
enough for me fourthly and lastly the
replayability of this game is definitely
there I was getting my sister to start
her game profile on breath of the wild
on my switch a few days ago and just so
happened to be present for the opening
and all of a sudden the hundreds of
hours that I've poured and are still
pouring into the game just washed away I
wanted to pick up that controller and go
adventure all over again from ground
zero
they definitely did this
right now okay it's not my favorite
Zelda game I'm just going to go ahead
and say that because above all other
aspects of the Zelda games story has and
always will matter most to me and
breasts of the wild story was not really
anything special just be playing it on
but that's hardly what makes bread the
wild great adventure makes it great
obviously great game rev the wild is a
great game it's phenomenal actually I
will definitely be replaying it sometime
in the future but I mean that'll be like
a long long time from now especially
with all the DLCs coming used like I'm
ready for hard mode okay and that news
story or whatever coming because
Christmas like bring it on
Nintendo anyway that's my honest review
of the great and magnificent breadth of
the wild thank you for sticking around
and watching and hey drop me a like if
you liked it and subscribe for even more
this is the one and only master Hondo
bandits signing out peace
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]